hi this was a traveling somewhere she
was in a boat and he's he's in with a
bunch of Catholics and they find out
that he's a Protestant and they would be
think about throwing him over crowding
essentially and so what does he do
luckily he has a rosary he gets out his
rosary inserts starts you know he
doesn't know what he's doing he's just
like the beat not maybe Malone well it
was like this he was kind of a timid
fellow the card was in a similar it
wasn't it wasn't about religion at that
point he was in a boat and they wanted
to throw him overboard take his money so
did he do he got out his sword and he's
connecting all these guys up I said okay
we're getting to shore and if anything
happens before that I'm going to stick
him two very different attitudes they
card is very practical he thinks that
you can solve things you know just by
looking at it purely human attitudes
this should sound familiar if you go in
chat rooms where debates are taking
place about whether religion and he has
anything to do with ethics don't you
hear things like this
there's an entire movement out there
people who think that religion has
nothing to contribute as a matter of
fact all it's done is cause a lot of
problems get it out of the way now we
can live a truly human truly rational
life again they're assuming this is very
rigid divided between faith and reason
brunch big Leon brunschwig he adopts a
different position he's also a
rationalist and the think that he has is
going to sound familiar to you too as
well he says well I wouldn't understand
myself a recognize myself if
Christianity hadn't existed Christianity
made a huge impact on our cultural
cultural heritage but what was
Christianity what was religion
altogether it's really just human
rationality or the human mind expressing
itself in a infantile in a crude way
through images eventually we get we get
past that sort of stuff and we become
much more rational we strip reason of
all of these silly superstitious
elements so what he is saying is really
everything on this side is just sort of
pre figurations of what's on this side
and there is like some other
philosophers like Hagel he's like some
of the secularists today you know it's
not even really a question of whether
religion is false it's just you know
it's not as advanced never heard
anything long these sort of lines so
brunch Vegas is uh is taking that point
so those are rations rationalists think
that there can't be any such thing as
Christian philosophy there were also
some religious thinkers who thought that
you couldn't have Christian philosophy
and Jill so calls them theologians and
what would we call them over here in
English would call them feed a ests is
that a term that you guys are familiar
with fede ism yes who can get some sort
of like you what that means to get feed
is petroleum is a sort of classic easy
for Peter Damian in the Middle Ages
Peter Damian said that in grammar was
the devil's tool really you know for
Peter danea anything other than prayer
and the Bible you were trying to
optimize anything else is probably going
to get you in trouble and you know if
the devil invented grammar what about
philosophy oh you better not do that and
human reason is so we it's liable just
to lead you in the traps so you better
not use it where do you hear things like
this
you've heard things like this right yes
where do you order to see things like
this game
probably not the ology classes
or doesn't come up
it is every single possible interesting
issue addressed immediately by scripture
so that we never need to use reason and
we ought to distrust it and root it out
no no there are people who think that
though right there are people who have
answers about well that's theologians
and it can be very angry like lexington
or Damien was or check out there till he
knows you know is pretty vehement about
this Luther's benefits that although
Luther actually does quite a bit of
reasoning himself but Luther says to
pretty crude things about reason doesn't
and since I don't know you know what the
campus policy is about about a crude
language I'm not going to say Nia but
you can look them up and he says some
pretty good things about of things there
was a very earthy guy so that's
theologian support or feet ism and say
well okay to extreme sides maybe meet in
the middle well some of the people in
the middle kept this middle kept this
divided some of the people that we call
neo scholastics these were thinkers in
the catholic church who were primarily
told us they were influenced by st.
thomas and they get their impetus they
really get under way after the papal
encyclical attorney patras which calls
for restoration not only of Christian
philosophy but but of the philosophy of
st. Thomas and the way that they were
interpreting Thomas was that there's
there's theology and there's philosophy
and theology is in higher up
philosophies down here philosophy uses
purely natural reason and the philosophy
of the intimus philosopher should really
be no different than the
anybody else because it's using pure
natural reasons so if it's any good it
is going to be just as appealing to
anybody else whether they have any
grounds of faith or not and they very
much distrusted theology they their view
as soon as you cross this line and start
doing theology the game is over so you
might say well why are they doing Thomas
and them in the first place then why not
just do John Dewey or Bertrand Russell
some other more contemporary losses well
you know how this was a great
philosopher and presumably he understood
a lot of things and so we just have to
remember that and follow in his
footsteps and there were the great many
books that were written Christian
philosophy or scholastic philosophy that
were basically just manuals and Thomas
had the answer to everything it was very
much I actually called it a
fundamentalism of the soul the topical
sounds requires as great works are
called somas there's a summa theologica
some cultures and Chile cultured in two
days and you have some Thomas now think
that you don't have to think about
anything I page through these and Thomas
has the answer somewhere so no question
you know prema prema parsed question 23
article blah blah blah blah blah here's
the answer well that's does anything
sound rational these needle scholastics
were not philosophers at the top so
let's talk about some of the
philosophers who actually did have
something some good positions who had
some interesting positions now we've
looked at the people who said you can't
do it has to be a dividing line between
these and I'm only going to talk about
three different philosophers I want to
keep it
simple two of them were really good
friends with each other and they lined
up against the other one all three of
them should have been good friends with
each other but there was kind of a
failure of Christian charity going on
between them that that's rather
inexplicable because blown doll is in
some respects the philosopher of chair
here we see him being
uncharacteristically unch arable towards
Jill saw more of town and both of them
are equally mean to him and their
positions are actually quite compatible
they didn't think they were there must
have been some sort of weird personality
conflict going on but I've never been
able to really figure out okay jokes all
actually all three of these guys have
something in common they are formed in
the French secular philosophical schools
none of them go to count the schools
they they all decide to go for one
reason one reason or another few the
ecole normale in france which at that
time was just you know viciously sapphic
you were a christian you were coming in
for a lot of ridicule one of the things
that blown down heard somebody say that
was sort of just taken for granted as
part of the attitude was what does some
obscure event nineteen hundred years ago
in some backwater the Roman Empire have
anything to do with flaws talk about the
Christ event that was the prevailing
view and so these guys are getting
formed all of them well not all of them
two of them as Catholics we're coming
from you know very strong Catholic
families and have a good formation
intellectual before they get there
they're they're going right into the
Lions Den and wanted they do that Jill
some does that because he says well it
was the only place to do philosophy why
does belong del do it lonedell is a
somewhat grander scheme he is going to
this
his intellectual apostolate he is going
to tackle philosophy from within and
find ways to show it that he has to
return to Christianity kind of ambitious
project so Moret actually converts to
eastern town an atheist makes it to
school gets influenced by this this
Catholic mystic Liam block gets him to
go to baritones classes baritone is not
a Catholic he's not even a Christian
he's actually more or less secularized
jus and but he's opening up philosophies
opening up metaphysics more intense
starts to see that there could be
something to it he also meets this nice
girl Raisa and in that time and they
they both start attending these classes
and he converts and now he becomes a
major Catholic philosopher as well so
all three of these guys have seen both
sides yeah we could you just write their
names up on the board chase people may
not know how to spell those
then please oh no I do have a website
that i have created dealing with these
debates that i'm going to show you a
little bit later they'll have come all
of this as well so it was your song asks
was there a Christian philosophy how
could you answer this question one of
the ways you can answer this question is
about looking at history were there any
philosophies he asks in which if
Christianity haven't come on the scene
and contributed some ideas or something
to that philosophy that philosophy would
not exist and you know what's the answer
if you actually look in a fairly one
buyers way at history what sticks alarms
what's the students in Augustine as a
philosopher could his philosophy exist
if Christianity and not come on scene
how many of your bread watch quite a few
how many of you have read the
confessions and read either the chapter
that deals with the will or the chapters
that deal with time and creation towards
the end which may
so the question that you have to ask
yourself could Augustine have had the
understanding of creation of nothing
they you unpack and he works with he
applies reason to understanding could
even have that idea just on his own or
did Christianity contribute that I did
to him well you know who's he influenced
by what what what philosophers is he
drawing he is drawing on Plato he was
drawing on Neoplatonic thought and
potatoes but is the notion of creation
not nothing him tied up does anybody
read Plato's Timaeus to drop a reading
in flames to miss this match you were a
lot of Gnostic God creates the world but
he doesn't create it nothing he creates
a lot of stuff that's on there he calls
God the Demiurge something that gets at
the Gnostic cosmology later not so
Austin got some ideas from Christianity
that are very clearly from Christianity
that he works